was ist denn da los immer mehr
verschwörungstheorien sind im umlauf am
letzten wochenende sind sogar leute auf
die straße gegangen und haben
transparente hochgeladen die auf den
falschen behauptungen basieren aber
warum glauben die menschen denn daran
wahrscheinlich liegt der grund in der
evolution und verschwörungstheorien sind
dort wohl wichtige überlebens und
bewältigungsstrategien gewesen also doch
etwas gutes klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen klicks
und gibt es übrigens jetzt auch als
podcast für all diejenigen die etwas auf
die ohren wollen die links sind unten in
der video beschreibung
verschwörungstheorien haben gerade in
dieser angespannten zeit der korona
krise hochkonjunktur
mit dabei auch mehr oder weniger
prominente leute sie unterstellen der
regierung düstere machenschaften
zweifeln an den wissenschaftlichen
studien von virologen und virologen und
teilen mit ihren fans und follower
thesen mit denen sie zu erklären glauben
was gerade passiert mit dabei attila
hildmann der bei facebook behauptet dass
wir kurz vor der abschaffung der
demokratie stecken und geheime kräfte
gerade dabei sein ein zitat neue
weltordnung zu erschaffen die schuld für
alles schiebt er bill gates in die
schuhe
auch ganz vorne mit dabei xavier naidoo
der schon seit einigen jahren immer mal
wieder mit rassistischen äußerungen
auffällt auch er teilt mit seinen fans
wilde und absurde theorien zur corona
pandemie
man muss schon festhalten denen ist fast
kein gedanke zu blöd und das ist super
gefährlich für uns alle
viele corona verschwörungstheorien haben
eines gemeinsam die idee dass hinter der
aktuellen lage eine geheime
weltregierung steckt als angeblicher
beweis taucht immer wieder das
youtube-video von ken jepsen auf dabei
handelt es sich um einen ehemaligen
radiomoderator in seinen videos teilt ja
schon seit längerer zeit antisemitische
verschwörungstheorien von sich selbst
behauptet er aber absurderweise kein
antisemit zu sein auch auf youtube geht
gerade eines seiner videos ferrari
verbreitet kennen jetzt neben
verschwörungstheorien auf falsche
behauptungen über die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu und eine
angeblich geplante impfpflicht bill
gates und das handeln der polizei bill
und melinda gates sollen demnach
nicht nur die gesundheitsbehörden
unterwandern sondern auch die deutsche
bundesrepublik hecken und so ganz allein
über das wohl unserer gesellschaft
entscheiden viele seiner behauptungen
sind bereits eingehend überprüft und als
lügen entlarvt worden war ließ hat er zb
ein erfrischendes video zugemacht so zum
beispiel die wilde these dass die
bill-und-melinda-gates-stiftung die whu
zu mehr als 80 prozent finanziere oder
aber dass die bundesregierung zitat
durch die hintertür eine impfpflicht
plane auch wenn eine impfpflicht erstens
nichts schlimmes ist noch keine impfung
hat irgendwelche schlimmen folgen gehabt
schlimme folgen folgen gibt es schon
beispiel masern dann müssen wir ja eine
autismus epidemie haben wenn die
verschwörungstheorien stimmen würden
gibt es also nicht und sie ist in diesem
fall auch gar nicht geplant also die
impfpflicht inhaltlich also nichts
dahinter hat der youtube algorithmus
jetzt trotzdem verstanden dass diese
inhalte gerade beliebt sind so wird es
an immer mehr zuschauer ausgespielt und
das ist gefährlich mit dabei werden auch
leute sein die so das erste mal mit
verschwörungstheorien in kontakt kommen
und so fatalerweise in deren bann
gezogen und manipuliert werden und
manche von denen sind auch gewaltbereit
nur noch mal zur klarstellung es geht
hier nicht um freie meinungsäußerung
sondern um falschinformationen wir haben
erfreulicherweise nach dem mittelalter
wo juden als brunnenvergifter verfolgt
wurden oder wir menschen aufgrund von
ziemlich abwegigen in den mit aderlass
oder brechmitteln behandelt haben und
sie trotzdem oder deshalb starben
wir haben uns auf ein prinzip
konzentriert und zwar die logik und das
haben wir zu nie gekannter perfektion
getrieben nicht nur sterben heute
deutlich weniger menschen durch
behandlungen und werden auch viel viel
älter
wir haben es auf den mond geschafft eine
unglaubliche leistung nur möglich mit
wissenschaft und wie funktioniert sie
super einfach es wird eine theorie aus
erfahrung zum beispiel aufgestellt und
dann wird sie überprüft und immer wieder
vor allem mit annahmen die gegen sie
sprechen gestresst die meisten theorien
überleben das nicht aber manche werden
immer und immer wieder belegt wie zum
beispiel die relativitätstheorie eine
unglaubliche zivilisations leistung eine
wirklich ziemlich abenteuerliche theorie
einer verschwörungstheorie aber die war
dann absolut konsistent und eben immer
wieder wurde sie durch expert
momente bestätigt das ist der große
unterschied für verschwörungstheorien
gilt eben beides nicht sie sind nicht
konsistent und zweitens brechen sie bei
ihrer überprüfung in sich zusammen und
es gibt eben kein anderes prinzip als
die logik wie es heute es ist das
ausgeben was sollte dass sein glaube das
ist ein anderer bereich und eben
spekulativ sprich mit der realität hat
das nichts zu tun und kann es auch gar
nicht deswegen auch mein appell youtube
muss viel härter gegen solche videos
vorgehen ist kann nicht sein dass kanäle
mit einem solch ausgemachten stoß solche
reichweiten erzielen youtube muss jetzt
zeigen dass es den kampf gegen
verschwörungstheorien ernst meinen und
maßnahmen ergreift by the way twitter
wird diese inhalte jetzt löschen wie
gefährlich das ist untermauern auch
zahlen und fakten bei der letzten mittel
studie der friedrich-ebert-stiftung
haben 50 prozent der deutschen angegeben
dass sie lieber ihren gefühlen glauben
als expertinnen und experten das ist
wirklich eine extrem hohe und
besorgniserregende zahlen
das macht eine sache ganz deutlich viele
menschen sind verunsichert und haben
angst davor die kontrolle zu verlieren
sie suchen nach strategien um damit
umzugehen und genau das lässt
verschwörungstheorien größer werden denn
dadurch wird die welt vermeintlich
wieder ein wenig strukturierte
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
konnten in der vergangenheit beobachten
dass bedrohungen und unsicherheiten wie
etwa aids oder auch terroranschläge die
menschen für verschwörungstheorien
empfänglicher machen pia lamberti
veröffentlicht dazu jetzt ein buch ist
erscheint am freitag der link ist unten
in der video beschreibung fake facts wie
verschwörungstheorien unser denken
bestimmen der glaube an verschwörung war
schon immer in der gesellschaft
verbreitet das ist kein neues phänomen
also nehmen wir mal das thema impfungen
das gerade ja viele menschen auch
mobilisiert 2009 10 haben knapp 20
prozent geglaubt dass es bei impfung um
eine verschwörung handelt das ist jede
fünfte person in deutschland das heißt
man hat hier ein extrem großes potenzial
aus dem man auch mobilisieren kann
dazu kommt dass in der krise wie jetzt
menschen tendenziell auch er an
verschwörungen glauben also dass eine
situation in der menschen einen
kontrollverlust erleben in denen sie das
gefühl haben ja sie sind nicht mehr in
der lage zu steuern was da eigentlich
gerade passiert man wird ja mit
unglaublichen informationen konfrontiert
die man auch noch nicht mehr versteht
man hat ängste da doch verschwörungs
erzählung einfach an diese geben dingen
oder ereignissen also plötzlich wieder
einen sinn zumindest in den augen ihrer
anhängerinnen und anhänger ihr glaube an
verschwörung macht sie selbst zu etwas
besonderem ich kenne das von meiner
arbeit als sondern ist wenn ich etwas er
recherchiert habe und zu einem ergebnis
komme fühle ich mich gut und bin stolz
auf dieses wissen ich habe das große
bedürfnis ist auch allen anderen
mitzuteilen ähnlich beim glauben an eine
verschwörung auch hier haben die
anhängerinnen und anhänger das gefühl
etwas zu wissen was viele andere noch
nicht wissen
man fühlt sich einzigartig wir haben
viele andere menschen der regierung
hinterherlaufen und einem riesigen
komplett auf sitzen nur ich als
richtiger journalist habe handwerkszeug
das mir hilft thesen geschichten
theorien zu überprüfen nicht so
dezidiert wie forschende kommen wir
gleich zu aber immerhin das
quellenstudium ich überprüfe einfach
mehrere quellen oder in anderen fällen
mache ich immer eine gegen recherche und
leider auch das ist der unterschied zum
bürgerjournalismus meistens recherchiere
ich dinge kaputt sie halten der
überprüfung nicht stand und in der
wissenschaft da überprüfen die
forschenden die thesen nicht mit quellen
die ja immer von jemand geschrieben
wurden also sekundär sind und so eben
nur mittelbar informationen bieten sie
gehen direkt ans objekt sie überprüfen
mit messungen experimenten beobachtung
die realität und dann machen noch
zusätzlich mehrere forschungsgruppen
ähnliche studien und nur nur dann wenn
mehrere studien zum selben ergebnis
kommen nur dann werden erkenntnisse als
gewonnen bezeichnet sie sind bestätigt
bei der relativitätstheorie ist das zum
beispiel der fall oder beim klimawandel
die beläge sind überwältigend doch es
gibt eben einen guten grund für die
verbreitung von verschwörungstheorien
ich hatte es eben erwähnt diejenigen die
sie verbreiten machen sich automatisch
zu etwas besonderem
das ist auch einfach so dass man sich
über den glauben an verschwörung das
selbstwert nochmal den selbstwert noch
mal verstärken kann erhöhen kann er so
man hat in studien zeigen können dass
ein bedürfnis nach einzigartigkeit den
glauben und verschwörungen vorher sagt
man ist dann plötzlich die person die
scheinbar die wahrheit weist während die
anderen ja in diesem weltbild dann die
angeblichen schlag schafe sind in
anführungsstrichen
oder eben teil der verschwörung und
umgekehrt sind es wohl auch bestimmte
persönlichkeitsstrukturen die dazu
führen verschwörungstheorien ernst zu
nehmen egal welche theorie da kann es
auch mal um rauchmelder gehen das kann
man ob ccs in experimenten zeigen wir
haben uns das angeguckt würde
wir haben zur verschwörungs erzählungen
damals ausgedacht die gab es da noch
nicht dass weil die rauchmelder
verschwörung angeblich verbreiten die
schallwellen machen krank und ein
pensionierter ingenieur hätte das
herausgefunden so jetzt haben wir
us-amerikanischen probanden erzählt dass
einmal in der einen bedingung eine
mehrheit der deutschen das glauben würde
in der anderen eine minderheit der
deutschen
wenn leute von dem thema noch keine
ahnung haben wollen die tendenz eher der
mehrheit das ist also ein hinweis aber
der ist wahrscheinlich was gerade für
menschen die aber starb die insgesamt an
verschwörungen glauben dreht sich der
effekt um und plötzlich ist es so dass
sie sogar bei einer verschwörungs
erzählung erde minderheit darum klar ist
diese zeit ist eine schwierige zeit für
uns alle und es tauchen fragen auf die
auch expertinnen und experten nicht
gleich eine eindeutige antwort liefern
können denn es müssen eben erst
erkenntnisse gewonnen werden das dauert
manchmal eben auch und in der
zwischenzeit werden studien mit
verschiedenen ergebnissen veröffentlicht
das ist die wissenschaft auf dem weg zur
erkenntnis und selbst politiker wie
christian lindner haben das noch nicht
ganz verstanden wenn sie fordern dass
die wissenschaft sich endlich mal
einigen soll das tut sie aber es ist
eben ein prozess und wir können ihn
beobachten und eben auch die
wissenschaft kann sich sogar ihren doch
das entspricht ihrem wesen und ist
keineswegs ein problem im gegenteil auch
virologin und virologen lernen dazu und
haben dann das recht sich zu korrigieren
so wurde aus dem zunächst heiß geliebten
halbgöttern wie dem virologen christian
drosten plötzlich boom männer und frauen
das muss man sich mal vorstellen die
fachleute bekommen morddrohungen weil
sie für die folgen der ausgangs
beschränkung verantwortlich gemacht
werden dabei ist es doch die aufgabe
immer weiter nach neuen erkenntnissen zu
suchen und diese suche auch nicht
abzuschließen und das vor allem in solch
einer neuen lage
wie der korona pandemie die nicht einmal
ein halbes jahr lang unser leben
begleitet so ist es das recht und die
aufgabe der wissenschaft antworten
mühsam zu erarbeiten und diese im
zweifelsfall dann auch
zu korrigieren doch das reicht vielen
nicht sie sind auf der suche nach
schnellen und einfachen antworten und
genau das bieten verschwörungs mythen
denn sie liefern auch auf schwierige
fragen sehr einfache antworten leider
sehr einfach anfällig für
verschwörungstheorien sind vor allem
menschen die ein simples weltbild haben
und alles in gut und böse einteilen
hinter einem dramatischen ereignis wird
eine böse macht vermutet es existieren
vorurteile und misstrauen anderen
gesellschaftlichen gruppen gruppen
gegenüber und das steigert sich dann zu
einem verschwörungs glauben hier wird
angenommen dass sich eine gruppe gegen
die andere verschworen hat um ihr zu
schaden
der angebliche gegner ist mächtig und
böse glied verbrechen und wird von den
anhängerinnen und anhänger regelrecht
dämonisiert verschwörungstheorien sind
also so erfolgreich weil sie den leuten
angebot liefern dinge zu erklären um
dabei sinn stiften allerdings nur
vermeintlich doch was macht eine
verschwörungstheorie zu einer
waschechten verschwörungstheorie hier
sind sich die expertinnen und experten
nicht ganz einig es gibt jedenfalls drei
entscheidende komponenten einplanen der
verfolgt wird eine gruppe die ihn
ausgeheckt hat und ihn angeblich
verfolgt und zudem der charakter des
geheim gut und böse duellieren sich was
ja vielleicht noch unsere
steinzeitlichen erfahrungen
widerspiegelt ein weiteres wichtiges
kriterium ist die vermeidung der
wahrheit die verschwörungstheorie
widerspricht also einer offiziell
anerkannten version eines ereignisses
oder vorgangs das häufigste motiv dabei
ist die weltherrschaft egal ob es
außerirdische juden oder freimaurer sind
gegen die sich das misstrauen richtet
ihnen wird unterstellt dass sie anderen
menschen schaden wollen und die
weltherrschaft an sich reißen wollen und
das ist übrigens lustig bei
verschwörungstheoretiker manchmal
vertreten die alle theorien alle
verschwörungstheorien gleichzeitig ja
fakt ist aber dass es in allen sozialen
schichten leute gibt die an
verschwörungstheorien glauben oft sind
diejenigen fans von
verschwörungstheorien die ihre eigene
identität in gefahr sehen beispielsweise
männer über 50 jahren die laut studien
häufig verschwörungstheorien im netz
kommentieren viele von ihnen haben wohl
angst vor den konsequenzen der
emanzipation und globalisierung so der
erklärungsversuch einiger forschenden
festhalten kann man wohl dass aldi
diejenigen die sich in eine extreme
richtung bewegen sei es nun politisch
oder religiös anfällig sind für
verschwörungstheorien denn viele von
ihnen fühlen sich wohl als außenseiter
verschwörungen können dann laut
forschung herhalten um für diesen
zustand eine vermeintliche erklärung zu
liefern immer wieder liefern sie dann
neue hinweise um ihre these zu stützen
was ihre these aber widerspricht wird
unter den tisch fallen lassen und das
ist eben anders als wissenschaft belege
werden nicht geliefert oder aber die
überprüfung der quellen fallen in sich
zusammen übrigens gibt es
verschwörungstheorien wahrscheinlich
schon ewig zumindest solange wie es auch
uns menschen gibt diese erklären
fachleute mit der evolution dass wir
menschen evolutionsbedingt vorsichtig
sein mussten um zu überleben förderte
demnach die bildung von
verschwörungstheorien für die menschen
sei es nämlich seit anbeginn sinnvoll
gewesen sich in gruppen zusammen zu tun
und sich anderen menschen gegenüber
misstrauisch zu zeigen
derjenige in der gruppe der oder die
also besonders skeptisch war und hinter
jedem handeln eines gegenübers eine
feindseligkeit vermutete bewahrte die
gruppe vor verhängnisvollen fehler und
motivierte zur ständigen überprüfung des
handelns das sind halt die leute die
nichts verpassen war sie zumindest in
der theorie schlange ob das in der
realität so aussieht ist noch mal was
anderes aber in der theoretischen
annahmen verpassen die keine
verschwörung
es hatte ja vielleicht damals offen sind
dass man nicht angegriffen wird man hat
immer hat immer jemanden der im blick
hatte sogar da könnte er was hinter
stecken
aber das ist wie gesagt noch eine offene
forschungsfragen die gerade bearbeitet
wird fest steht jedenfalls
verschwörungstheorien sind eine riesige
bedrohung für uns alle eine australische
studie legt nahe dass anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien dazu neigen
etablierte wissenschaftliche fakten
abzulehnen beispielsweise halten sie das
rauchen für unschädlich womit sie sich
am ende natürlich erst einmal sich
selbst schaden aber
verschwörungstheorien können nicht nur
dazu führen dass menschen sich selbst
schaden vor allem bei theorien die
bestimmte gruppen von menschen schlecht
machen besteht das risiko dass diese
gruppen auch körperlich angegriffen
werden wenn bei corona protesten nicht
die mindestabstände eingehalten werden
dann ist das potenziell tödlich für
menschen die dann später angesteckt
werden das hat jetzt auch die politik
auf den plan gerufen so warnt
beispielsweise der thüringer
innenminister jörg meyer von
spd vor einer zunahme von
verschwörungstheorien in der korona zeit
die vorstellung dass die pandemie
bewusst herbeigeführt wurde um das volk
zu kontrollieren und dahinter bill gates
oder andere vermeintlich finstere mächte
stecken reicht bis weit in die mitte der
gesellschaft hier kippt der protest
schnell ins antisemitische wenn menschen
kritik üben ist das selbstverständlich
in ordnung was uns alarmiert ist der
versuch von extremisten die proteste zu
kapern
markus kerber der staatssekretär im
bundesinnenministerium spricht sogar von
einem zitat weltweiten informations
kampf zu corinna
demnach wurde zunächst ein anstieg von
desinformation und propaganda aus dem
ausland festgestellt mittlerweile würden
sich die verschwörungstheorien aber auch
im inland verbreiten laut markus gerber
ist es wichtig dagegen zu halten mit
zitat fakten transparenz und einer
verteidigung der wissenschaft ein
absolut wichtiger punkt wissenschaft ist
ein universelles prinzip dass unsere
spezies eben unglaubliche erkenntnisse
und fortschritte gebracht hat
verschwörungstheorien führen uns gerade
wieder zurück ins mittelalter
und das schlimme sie verstärken sich
persönlich und auch in der gruppe das
liegt daran dass der glaube an eine
verschwörung eine bewältigung
beziehungsweise eine umgangs strategie
der fachbegriff doping strategie ist und
zum beispiel mit der korona pandemie
umgehen zu können bei dem glauben an
verschwörungen handelt sich eben auch
eine umweltstrategie bei der wir aber
befürchten sie tatsächlich eher eine ist
die das ganze noch mal stärker besteuert
also man keine studien auch zeigen dass
wenn menschen im labor eine
verschwörungs erzählung lesen also
einfach nur bunt gemischte gruppe egal
was die für von voreinstellungen hatten
wir lesen die verschwörungs erzählung
die fühlen sich danach machtloser
machtlosigkeit ist aber eben auch einer
der ursachen die zu mir verschwörungs
glaubens wird also befinden uns danach
einfach schnell genug dass eben diese
comics hatte dann wieder angewendet wird
man sie wieder machtloser und auf einmal
ist ja man in dieser abwärtsspirale
es muss man sich empirisch noch ein
bisschen genauer angucken es gibt bis
jetzt noch wenig längsschnittstudien
aber dass es so die vermutungen dass es
eben diese mechanismen sind es ist
tatsächlich allerhöchste zeit zu handeln
denn wir haben verschwörungstheorien in
ihrer gefährlichkeit viel zu lange
unterschätzt auch die
täter von hanau und alle glaubten an
verschwörungstheorien in manchen ländern
werden gerade 5 gegen mobilfunkmasten
angezündet weil die theorie verbreitet
wird dass sie die ursache für den
ausbruch des corona virus sind das alles
macht das problem deutlich ebenso wie
die studien die offenbaren dass sich
menschen mit verschwörungs glauben
gewalt als option für politisches
handeln ansehen und dass sie sich eher
politischen alternativen außerhalb des
demokratischen spektrums zuwenden wie
also geht man am besten mit anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien umgeht so fehlt es
an eindeutigen studien menschen die
gerade erst damit beginnen sich
verschwörungstheorien zuzuwenden sind
aber wohl noch am ehesten für fakten
empfängen nicht so bald sie dann
vollends überzeugt sind kann es
passieren dass sie durch starke
gegenargumente noch mehr an ihre eigene
theorie glauben und damit also das
gegenteil erreicht wird bei impfgegnern
zum beispiel gelten von ärztinnen und
ärzten vorgebrachte argumente als beweis
ihrer verschwörungstheorie weil sie ja
besagt dass medizinerinnen und mediziner
die pharmaindustrie unterstützen und
deshalb für das impfen werden ja da sind
dann wirklich hopfen und malz verloren
es kann also nur helfen die verbreitung
von verschwörungstheorien zu unterbinden
es steht ja verschwörungstheoretikern
vollkommen frei ihre theorien zu
überprüfen und zu belegen
freie meinungsäußerung ist ein wichtiges
gut aber fakten sind keine meinung und
falsche fakten sind gefährlich für
unsere gesundheit und unsere demokratie
nicht umsonst heißt es im pressekodex
des deutschen presserates die achtung
vor der wahrheit die wahrung der
menschenwürde und die wahrhaftige
unterrichtung der öffentlichkeit sind
oberste gebote der presse vielleicht
wäre es eine idee dass zum gesetz für
alle zu machen kopf einschalten bei
verschwörungstheorien dazu habe ich auch
mal ganz persönlich klartext gesprochen
denn das war nötig also anschauen de
anklicken hand schauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal mit mir übrigens
diskutieren kann man jetzt nicht mehr
auf wozzeck sondern aufstellungen die
links dazu sind unten in der video
beschreibung ja und ansonsten bis dann
dran